you had a huge hit with spencer
confidential on netflix
um i know that they released the numbers
and you know uh
it was a huge hit um i know that you and
mark had talked about making more of
spencer confidential movies
yes depending on how it went um so have
you guys talked about that
yeah for sure we're deep into the script
brian huggleman who wrote the first
script
just turned in a first draft last week
so
we're definitely going to do spencer
confidential too we're just trying to
figure out the days
is it do you have a story already that
you're pulling from or
we do yes okay i won't don't ask you
anymore
look you and mark obviously are best
friends
listen i'm sure you text all the time
really close uh friends you guys have
an amazing track record um are you also
talking about other projects or do you
think that spencer confidential 2
is the next thing um for mark and i
yeah yeah i think i think um you know
he's in germany and i'm making a film
i'm gonna do
uh something else before spencer
confidential too
but we're definitely gonna do that and
you know i'm sure mark and i will be
85 90 years old one day making movies
together
you know we we're we love working
together
so do you think that next year you're
definitely going to be filming it
max venture confidential i think that'll
probably be um
well either end very end of 2021 or
beginning of
2022.